OVERWHELMING PSYCHOLOGICAL
TRAUMA DEMAND WE SEEK JUSTICE
AND THAT WE TAKE BROADER ACTION
TO PROTECT LIFE.
TODAY, THE LAKE COUNTY STATE'S
ATTORNEYS OFFICE HAS CHARGED
ROBERT CRIMO III WITH SEVEN
COUNTS OF FIRST DEGREE MURDER
FOR THE KILLING SPREE HE HAS
UNLEASHED AGAINST OUR COMMUNITY.
THESE ARE JUST THE FIRST OF MANY
CHARGES THAT WILL BE FILED
AGAINST MR. CRIMO.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
THERE WILL BE MORE CHARGES.
WE ANTICIPATE DOZENS OF MORE
CHARGES CENTERING AROUND EACH OF
THE VICTIMS.
PSYCHOLOGICAL VICTIMS, VICTIMS,
ATTEMPT MURDER CHARGES,
AGGRAVATED CHARGES, THERE WILL
BE DOZENS MORE CHARGES AGAINST
MR. CRIMO, BUT THESE SEVEN
COUNTS OF FIRST DEGREE MURDER
WILL LEAD TO A MANDATORY LIFE
SENTENCE SHOULD HE BE CONVICTED
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE.
NONE OF THESE CHARGES WOULD BE
POSSIBLE AGAIN WITHOUT THE
UNBELIEVABLE EFFORTS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I CANNOT THANK THEM ENOUGH.
I HAVE TO THANK THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE LAKE COUNTY STATE'S
ATTORNEYS OFFICE WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SINCE THE MOMENT THAT WE
IDENTIFIED A SUSPECT.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO UNDERSTAND
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS WELL
ORCHESTRATED AND CAREFULLY
PLANNED CRIME.
TOMORROW MORNING AT THE LAKE
COUNTY COURTHOUSE, WE WILL ASK A
JUDGE TO HOLD MR. CRIMO WITHOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF BAIL.
AS I MENTIONED OUR SUPPORT FOR
VICTIMS STARTED TODAY.
BOTH FROM THE STATE'S ATTORNEYS
OFFICE, THE MAYOR'S OFFICE, THE
CITY OF HIGHLAND PARK, THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT, THE FBI
VICTIM ASSISTANCE GROUP.
WE WILL GUIDE THEM THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS AND DEAL WITH THE
TRAUMA THAT WILL RIPPLE FOREVER
OUTSIDE OF THE COURTROOMS.
BUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THERE
ARE NO MORE VICTIMS?
WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
CELEBRATION OF FREEDOM HAS ENDED
IN DESPAIR FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO DIED STEPS
FROM HERE LOST THEIR FREEDOM.
ALL OF IT.
EVERY OUNCE OF FREEDOM THEY HAD.
THE FREEDOM TO LOVE.
THE FREEDOM TO LEARN AND THE
FREEDOM TO LIVE A FULL LIFE.
THEIR FREEDOM MATTERS, TOO.
WE MUST DO MORE AS WE THINK AND
REFLECT UPON THEIR FREEDOM ON
THIS JULY 5th.
ILLINOIS HAS A STRONG RED FLAG
LAW THAT KEEPS COMMUNITIES SAFE
AND RESPECTS EVERYONE'S RIGHTS.
WE MUST VASTLY INCREASE
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION ABOUT
THIS RED FLAG LAW CALLED THE
ILLINOIS FIREARM RESTRAINING
ORDER.
THE GOAL OF THIS TOOL IS TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THOSE AROUND
THEM.
IT ALLOWS COURT TO TEMPORARILY
REMOVE GUNS AND PREVENT THE
PURCHASE OF NEW GUNS BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO POSE A THREAT.
THIS ALLOWS TEMPORARY REMOVAL
AND PROHIBITS THE NEW PURCHASE
DURING THE DURATION OF THE
ORDER.
IT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
STABILIZE THEIR BEHAVIOR, SEEK
TREATMENT AND ACCESS OTHER
RESOURCES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
MUST INVEST IN TO GIVE THOSE WHO
NEED HELP.
BUT SEPARATE FROM THESE RED FLAG
LAWS, WHICH ARE VERY POWERFUL IN
ILLINOIS, WE SHOULD ALSO BAN
ASSAULT WEAPONS IN ILLINOIS AND
BEYOND.
THE ASSAULT WEAPON BAN WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN 1994.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT LASTED FOR TEN YEARS.
AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT MASS
SHOOTINGS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY WENT DOWN DURING THOSE
TEN YEARS.
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT SAME BAN IN
ILLINOIS.
AND BEYOND.
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THE LAKE COUNTY STATES ATTORNEYS
OFFICE STANDS WITH THE PEOPLE OF
HIGHLAND PARK.
AS I SAID EARLIER, THIS IS WHERE
I AM RAISING MY FAMILY, ALSO.
OUR VIOLENT CRIMES UNIT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD THIS CASE.
AS I SAID, IT IS AN ACTIVE AND
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
OUR VICTIM SERVICES UNIT WILL
ANSWER EVERY QUESTION, EVERY
TEXT, EVERY PHONE CALL, AND
EVERY CONCERN.
WE WILL STAND WITH THE SURVIVORS
OF THIS AWFUL CRIME FOR AS LONG
AS NECESSARY.
IN THE COURTROOM, WE WILL SEEK
THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE AGAINST
THIS OFFENDER.
NOT BECAUSE WE SEEK VENGEANCE
BUT BECAUSE JUSTICE AND THE
HEALING PROCESS DEMAND IT.
AS WE GO FORWARD IN THE
COURTROOM AND IN THE COMMUNITY,
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THE HORROR THAT MARKED
THESE STREETS, THAT ECHOED FROM
THESE BUILDINGS, NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT THIS TIME, I WOULD INTRODUCE
U.S. ATTORNEY AND REALLY OUR
PARTNER IN THIS INVESTIGATION SO
FAR, U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN LAUSCH.
>> I'M THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY HERE IN ILLINOIS.
I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE SAME
WORDS WE JUST HEARD AND COMMEND
ALL OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS AND AGENCIES
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY.
IN ALL OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
FOR EVERYTHING THEY DID TO
BRAVELY PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE TO HELP OTHERS IN NEED.
OUR OFFICE, THE U.S. ATTORNEYS
OFFICE, AND OUR OTHER DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE COMPONENTS, MOST
NOTABLY THE FBI AND THE ATF,
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO
INVESTIGATE THIS HORRIFIC
ATTACK.
WE HAVE BEEN AND WE WILL BE
REMAIN IN REGULAR COMMUNICATION
WITH THESE PARTNERS AND IN
PARTICULAR, THE LAKE COUNTY
STATE'S ATTORNEYS OFFICE.
I'VE BEEN IN REGULAR CONTACT
WITH STATES ATTORNEY REINHARDT
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THESE STATE MURDER CHARGES ARE
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DEPLOY OUR
FEDERAL RESOURCES IN
COLLABORATION WITH THESE STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERS TO EN